[Music]
heyyou we're back once again for the
matinee show yeah I think the first one
is Z right it is now this is one that
came out I believe it came out late last
year it premiered actually at the same
Film Festival that the that Daniel isn't
real also premiered at which we reviewed
a little while back this one actually
just dropped on shudder just a couple
days ago I believe this is a Canadian
film the guy that directed it is Brandon
Kristensen and he also directed one
called stillborn which is also on
shudder and which is also quite good if
you want to check that one out this one
this was a good one I liked this movie a
lot did we see this on shudder or we see
a shudder yeah I just added it on
shudder like a few days ago it was it
was a good movie it's it's basically a
poltergeist movie / yes and it kind of
does kind of fit poltergeist phenomena
think about it I mean you know whenever
an object moves they weren't quite
looking at it and it was something kind
of like the creation of a subconscious
yeah you-you-you guess there might have
been some outside force - maybe
something diamond demonic but that's
always been kind of in poltergeist cases
theorized that it is a combination of
you know I mean a kid and some external
yeah but either way that that was pretty
good movie good it was like really
really well done I thought I mean the
thing about it okay so basically it's a
pretty like um simple setup it's like
you know there's through your regular
kind of middle-class family they have a
son named Joshua and Joshua starts
having an imaginary friend which you
know no one thinks is particularly weird
but then as it kind of goes on [ __ ] gets
like stranger and stranger like he
starts the kid starts insisting that you
know they put out like two sandwiches so
that Z which is what he calls the
imaginary friend can have a sandwich too
and then the mom ends up finding out
that like he gets he gets suspended from
school right or something like that and
like now the kids want to play with ya
and she like is the last to know about
this because I guess her husband had
been like keeping some stuff from her
too but I guess like all
his little friends and everything were
you know their moms didn't want him
playing with them anymore and she could
even though he seems like he's acting
fairly normal other than having this
imaginary friend however it then starts
to you know come to pass that perhaps
this imaginary friend is not so
imaginary after all yeah this part of
the movie really kind of gave me an
Amityville Horror vibe with the whole
Jodi phenomena yeah it's kind of
reminded me a lot of that yeah not quite
as as bad as the Amityville though I
loved Amityville Horror when it came out
as a kid you watch it now it's not that
good yeah it's an okay movie I don't
think it holds up as well as maybe some
other from those know in that era no it
looks like a made-for-tv movie Oh
nowadays although I've never seen it on
blu-ray true it may hold up a little bit
better on blu-ray
maybe maybe I'll get it on blu-ray one
of these days yeah if I can find it for
decent price but it kind of gave me that
feeling that I got when I saw The
Amityville Horror background kid
of course I cuz not as scared yeah
nothing scares me like you know like it
used to when you're a kid but yeah it
had that tone I liked it it's good yeah
and this it really had some really
nicely creepy imagery there was there
some really really [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
and like even just some stuff that's
like really simple like when she first
starts thinking that she sees this thing
or you know begins to suspect that maybe
there is some something to this that
it's not an imaginary friend after all
it's like there's just something really
simple like you know one of his toys
like an alphabet toy that just like
makes this like kind of robotic like
sound all the time and like kind of
flashes and stuff like in his room like
some of his toys like coming on like
when no one's in the room and [ __ ] like
that and also I have to say that when
the kid draws the Z on the wall like of
his page where he painted it on there or
something like that that was a pretty
disturbing gave me a little bit of a
babadook kind of vibe I guess he that's
a little bit like that having
experienced poltergeist phenomenon
myself personally as a kid this does
kind of remind
you know what it's like this is a very
exaggerated you know well yeah but it's
a movie you have to exaggerate it for I
think to make a good movie documentary
no but movie yeah but this is that's
pretty much it yeah - ominous yeah like
I was sitting there watching that and
it's like I got like totally sucked into
the story of like it was going on with
this kid and and this family and
everything and then they're like the
tension between the husband and wife
because he's like keeping info firmer
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and then
Hearne like not knowing all of this
stuff that's happening like at school
and with the kids friends and everything
and him seeing seeming like totally
normal when he's around her but then
like you know the dad being kind of like
absent all the time it's kind of like
you know the episodes of a haunting
where the dudes always at work cuz she's
like a stay-at-home mom and you know
she's trying to tell him hey I think
that I think his merrie friend might be
real and of course the husband doesn't
believe her and think she's nuts and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so and then she
kind of maybe starts to think she's nuts
- and it's like they have to go to a
psychiatrist and all this other kind of
[ __ ] but there's like some really really
cool like um I was one scene in
particular like where she's in a bathtub
and that's all I'm gonna say
yeah but that was like a creepy creepy
like [ __ ] and also the one scene with
the stairs and the kid that was like I'm
legit was like yeah she's seeing real
phenomena happening but she's also
seeing like a mixture of I guess
possibly hallucinations or visions or
you're not really sure apparitions of
some sort but what I really liked is the
part where she goes ahead and agrees to
marry it and Darren being very she's
actually interacting with it playing
lava games about not stepping on the
floor and it has a childlike character Z
this poltergeist yeah that fits right in
with you know what I saw yeah I mean it
had it's kind of like a childlike even
though it looks terrifying
yeah well reman Mountain poltergeist you
can see you know talk about it here on
the show it's a mixture of stuff you
know it'll scare you one minute and a
sudden you think it's funny and then it
starts doing funny stuff and then it
scares you again but
it did kind of have a menacing presence
to it sometimes you know yeah overall it
was disturbing yes you can't see it
because I mean there was one scene early
on where the kid was like he snuffed out
of the kitchen in the middle of the
night and he's like making Zia peanut
butter sandwich and he had like cut the
crusts off you know what I mean it was
he was just little and he wasn't
supposed to be using a knife and stuff
so it's like yeah that the kid was like
him but it's I mean there's kind of an
explanation for it later on but like you
said they leave it ambiguous yeah yeah
like what is it is it a ghost is it a
demon is it a [ __ ] monster is it is
it like a psychic emanation from from
her own subconscious it's all there to
me that's a poltergeist movie it yes I
mean that's kind of how I interpreted it
as well but I mean this one it's like I
said it's not a super original idea it's
very simple idea and as I said that you
know we reviewed Daniel isn't real which
was also kind of about an imaginary
friend too so it's kind of interesting
that they both premiered at the same
Film Festival but this is like a wildly
different tone to that one this is just
this is just um you know just a really
creepy poltergeist type movie that is
just really really it's not a super
original idea but it's just really
really well executed and it has like
some really really creepy imagery really
like dread inducing kind of shots it's
shot really beautifully the acting is
really good and it's just it's just a
really really solid horror movie I was
watching like another review of it where
they said that you know this you know is
probably it could be in the conjuring
universe except it's like way better
than many of the last movies that were
in the conjuring movies you know
universe that came out like the nun and
La Llorona and all those other kind of
movies this is like a you know a
thousand times better than those movies
this movie actually does stick to
classic poltergeist phenomena all right
it does stick to - what is it commonly
reported but the emphasis is slightly
different yeah in this one a poltergeist
is portrayed as being very coherent and
that it has a theme and a continuing
theme like a personality like a
personality yeah for my personal
experience of poltergeist that's not the
way they really are
a lot more wishy-washy there sometimes
[ __ ] it does this for a while
and doesn't wanna does this for a while
it changes with the environment you end
up in the end I was I was realizing that
it wasn't a it wasn't a a ghost or a
being or anything coherent it was a
phenomenon yeah that's what it was and
but this is a good movie this is real
close to what it's like when you when
you see it yeah when you have a
poltergeist phenomena like this I mean
yeah quite as coherent but yeah but I
mean you know if you're gonna do a movie
like a narrative you know you have some
kind of middle and an end there has to
like what kind of exactly like what kind
of focus movie is this what kind of
story is it so I understand why they did
it that way but if you see a real
poltergeist it's [ __ ] all over the
place it doesn't make any damn sense
there's no beginning middle or end and
it didn't mean anything in the end yeah
yeah but this was it yes real close this
movie's real close to the phenomena yeah
but I said this was like a really good
one like I said this guy Brandon
Kristensen his other movies stillborn is
also on shudder and that was also very
good if you want to check that out also
this is the same writer that did Grave
Encounters
I think Grave Encounters might be on
shutter two or maybe it's on Netflix cuz
I've watched that not too long ago and
that's also very good so you know these
are some guys that are making some good
[ __ ] like I said not super original
story but you know what is it's just you
have to take something like this and
just make like a really good creepy
enjoyable movie out of it and I think
they like knocked it out of the park
honestly so if you have a shudder like
definitely check it out it might be
streaming I think it's streaming on
somewhere else - I think it's on you can
I think you can rent it on youtube for
like three bucks or something like that
so if you want to watch it but I liked
it a lot it had just some really really
creepy scenes and like just really
creepy [ __ ] in it and one like like I
said this the part on the stairs like
that really shocking moment that really
like [ __ ] I mean you were sitting
right there when I was just like holy
[ __ ] yeah it it didn't have jump scares
person I really like in the conjuring
universe they were [ __ ] lots of damn
java.security
yes I got some pretty [ __ ] eerie [ __ ]
me personally I didn't see anything like
that in a polarized experience but that
feeling that you had yeah there's the
feeling that you get when your real
thing agency folks at a different way
yes
in reality it doesn't have to be that
dramatic to give you that [ __ ]
feeling yeah yeah but yeah I mean I
really really like this maybe a lot of
that was like super creepy and like I
said I've shut her check it out and
check out his other ones too because at
least stillborn is on there Grave
Encounters might be as well I can't
remember if it is but yeah check it out
you
all right so the second movie we watched
this week we just kind of picked it
randomly on well sort of randomly on
xbox rental now had you seen cuz Rob
movies sent us the trailer and then we
saw that it was for Linux on Xbox so
Tom's like Oh Rob told us to watch that
movie so we watched it yeah that's not
what it says well I said Rob showed that
too no showed that to me showed that to
me you know it was like what the [ __ ]
and I was like what the [ __ ] and I
watched the trailer and I'm like okay
yeah right the change so the trailer
looked funny yeah there's only like a
299 or 399 and it had it had Adrienne
Barbeau and it had to do the play Bishop
from aliens in it and have by land who
played a play to goth which girl a lot
of [ __ ] the Croke yeah she wasn't
she's been at a [ __ ] ton of stuff yeah I
hadn't seen her recently she's been well
I looked at her Wikipedia page real
quick and she's still working she's
gotta be 50 something years of movies TV
everything she's older than me she got
me 50 something years old yeah I gotta
be she looks great though she looks good
she looked great skinny boobs still
looks pretty she was always pretty but
she looked great and really for what
this movie is this is the this is what
it is I got a backup we're talking about
exorcism at 60,000 yeah you're supposed
to know that what this is okay this is
kind of like a laugh a minute movie that
you know and it's a midnight movie you
know it's like something back in the 80s
you'd rent it [ __ ] you're from your
local VHS
store when you were underage because you
getting couldn't get your hands on porn
so you watch this and it was [ __ ]
laughing laughing laughing it [ __ ]
laughing how stupid the movie is with
some boobs
totally totally on PC it's got everybody
some kind of stereotype everything is
outrageous and over the [ __ ] top it's
goofy [ __ ] silly humor that's not
well written but it's just kind of
[ __ ]
what's a good what's it's just just in
poor taste everything is in [ __ ] poor
taste but that's that's the genre it's
it's like a midnight movie Jenny I think
had a pro but I just accepted it for it
was I thought it was a masterpiece of
[ __ ] schlock that's what it is here's
well the the problem I had with it and
like I said it's you know the trailer
looked funny you know this has like some
big stars don't like it you know they're
they're essentially cameos
yeah and they kind of phoned it in but
yeah I mean bill Mosley is in this um
you know what I mean it's Adrienne
Barbeau is in it yeah [ __ ] like that and
it looked kind of funny there they were
shooting for like an airplane slash
Naked Gun yeah throwback like 70s 80s
yeah mashup of The Exorcist
anyway airplane and Twilight Zone yeah
nightmare it's sixty thousand very very
it's ever yeah so in in that way this is
really weird because it had that to it
but it also had that 90s scary movie you
know all this parodies they did have
scream and horror movies and stuff where
which I didn't think those movies were
funny either because most of them were
just kind of like hey we're doing this
scene from this familiar horror movie
except with tits
and I was like okay but um yeah so this
movie struck me very much like that and
it was kind of like a thing where I
think I don't know if this was the
directors intention it was directed by
Chad Ferran who also did a movie called
parasites back in 2016 which actually
was was quite good but this one it
seemed almost like I don't know if he
was trying to like be edgy or non-pc or
something like that of course well but
to me it just came across as like just
really lazy it seemed very it's like oh
look this guy's an Asian stereotype and
lo look there's a bloody tampon that
somebody a Dan oh yeah yeah it seemed
like it was just very try hard and a lot
of it it's really weird because a lot of
the dialogue it seemed like it was Adlon
I think it was it seemed like
a lot of it was just like non sequiturs
yeah and I was just like what what is it
I think like what are you even talking
about I think I think this is the fit
that the script was vague okay
yeah the script was very vague I think
each they knew how the story arc would
be but I think each each scene was semi
ad libbed
alright it seemed like improv and it
also seemed like what you're talking
about there used to be an old television
or cable TV program called MADtv this
reminded me of like an unfunny sketch on
that show they were about like that
except why exactly thankfully long one
big long MADtv skit yeah that was like
but I didn't mind it I liked it because
it was kind of the genre of it and I was
kind of laughing with the movie but also
laughing at the movie at the same time
and for what I paid I didn't feel like I
was ripped off it did make me laugh at
it it did stupid [ __ ] and it did some
over-the-top [ __ ] and and I just see to
me and not you not talk about Citizen
Kane no I knew that but it's like it
does seem to me that it was like it
thought that it was way more shocking or
funnier than it actually was
I think it was Mike I think it was made
quickly oh definitely I think I mean it
others and I mean the opening when it
first started like the opening scene
with the Exorcist and like the extras
going in there and like shooting the guy
in the head and like the guy going in
there discovering that he's killed his
entire family like while he was
possessed he's like he's running in
other rooms and you could just hear his
voice going oh no my mother
oh no okay that [ __ ] was funny yeah and
you know so the opening was funny the
score was great it's it the score
actually reminded me of like the
frighteners or something like that yeah
like an 80s like a real epic score so
it's just like right on board the movie
the movie looks good it's got fresh it's
got some facts yes once it gets on the
plane yeah it just seemed like it's very
I'm gonna use one of Gordon Ramsay's
favorite words it's very shambolic but
not in a good way it almost seemed like
I mean you could tell obviously they
filmed pretty much the entire thing in
this airplane set which is probably very
small
I think and I think they did this in a
clean editing was is all over the bazaar
it's like I didn't even [ __ ] and I
didn't even know like [ __ ] would happen
over here and then suddenly everyone's
over there with no I'm not going over
there like what the [ __ ] just happened
like what it is oh also the score which
is good sometimes it was mixed so high
that I couldn't hear what the people
were saying you know what I mean yeah
and also it doesn't help that like a lot
of the stares like you know bay links
character buy links character you know
she had like this really really really
thick accent cuz you they're going to
Vietnam it's like a Vietnamese airplane
or airplane or whatever and um so I
could barely understand what she was
saying and so I put the UM I put the the
closed captioning on and even then like
the closed captioning was clearly not
what the characters were saying yeah
like sometimes and I was just like what
the [ __ ] is happening it's like
everything just seemed really half-assed
and it's like [ __ ] like this could be
funny but like I said the thing that
happens with these type of parody movies
I've seen very funny parody movies but I
think this falls of the same thing is
like you know the scary movie franchise
where it's just it's it just seems like
they take like the laziest most obvious
route and it just comes across as like I
laughed a couple of times like the
scenes with Adrienne Barbeau pilot do
the whole thing though I was well I was
just kinda why is it's ridiculous but I
think any was supposed to be well
obviously it was supposed to be
ridiculous but I found it like really I
was just kind of like it was what it was
also a bro movie very much a pro movie
this Outernet I hate the target was I
think the target was second
well again teenage boys what I was gonna
say it was like what okay like when
Adrienne Barbeau was getting a trach
attacked by her dead dog which came back
to life the toxin was Pookie but yes
from which we thought was funny okay and
she gets scalped that was funny kind of
when somebody punches off Lance
Hendrickson's head funny yeah um other
than that I can't really think of the
opening funny other than that I couldn't
really think of anything like a couple
things were just like Oh huh you know
what I mean but other than that it's
like it wasn't if you know what I mean
it was the same kind of thing and I said
this on and Tom shitty movies I said
this was like
Holmes and Watson level like where some
of the ship was kind of funny but then
like some of it you it was just trying
so hard to be funny and it was just like
falling flat it was like watching like a
comedian like up on stage and they're
just like taking the pipe and you just
like it's like embarrassing like to
watch them it was kind of like that I
understand what Jenny said I understand
what Jenny's saying but I think she's I
think she's taking it too seriously
the problem with Holmes and Watson and
there were times at Holmes and Watson
that I [ __ ] laughed
okay the [ __ ] were they were trying to
stuff Queen began to put the problem
with Holmes and Watson is that if you
had paid to see Holmes with Watson in
the theatre like we were on [ __ ] all
day yes I would have felt ripped cuz it
would have cost you about 11 bucks to
pay for that right I see that on a
person all right
it was funny but it was an $11 funny it
was dumb funny was it $2.99 funny yeah
especially if you were yeah I could
drink it okay so we didn't pay much for
this movie
yeah downloaded it okay it'd probably
been better if we were drinking and if
we were dumber funnier if I was done if
I was drunker and okay this would have
been the movie the movie is what it is
you [ __ ] rented a movie caught with
that damn title okay well it looks funny
the previous one I thought it was kind
of funny but I thought it was funny it
seemed it was only like an hour and 27
minutes long and it seemed endless like
it would seem like it was never going to
it and I have to disagree on this
I thought by length [ __ ] carried the
movie she was probably the best thing it
was the best thing in it she was almost
in every damn scene and she was a funny
character and she was clowns her way
through this whole [ __ ] movie and
it's rare that it's rare that a [ __ ]
woman can clown her way through an hour
and a half full you know an hour and a
half a movie I think as the audience you
could still go along with it there was
some [ __ ] about that character I still
don't understand like what was that on
her forehead she had one big huge fat
eyebrow painted on and yeah hit bang
inside scenes if there is there's
something that wasn't there which I
don't know if that wasn't which doesn't
matter it doesn't matter in a movie that
we're not talking about Citizen Kane I
know that added to it for me their
attitudes vary when added to it for me
that that they were just making this
[ __ ] up as they were going along I
clearly and that they were pulling [ __ ]
out of their ass and I still liked it
alright it's sad because I like the
concept but it really seemed like they
took the easiest route for everything
just did everything like his house it
was just it was just a group of people
trying to onto the screen trying to make
me laugh that's all well which that
would have been cool but it's just like
a lot of it just wasn't funny it was
just kind of like yeah there's a
different had there been like better
comic timing or had they gone a little
bit clever what they should instead of
just being super obvious about
everything then it would have been
funnier I just did have better comic
writing yeah the writing was really
thing about an airplane airplane was
very well written and it was and and
laid out it was there was nothing left
to chance an airplane yeah every [ __ ]
thing was a gag or yeah see a parodies
like that I mean airplane was funny the
Naked Gun was funny parodies gonna be
funny this one was more spontaneous you
could tell they didn't really write a
lot of this [ __ ] and yeah I think I
think a lot of it was improv alright yes
yeah because some of it did it makes it
like characters would be having a
conversation like I'd be like what did
that mean and it seemed like they were
talking it seemed like they were having
two different conversations like you
know what I mean and I'm just like what
are they even talking about I didn't
like I didn't like it it just seemed
like a bunch of non sequiturs sometimes
yeah yeah but like but but from day one
I did not take this movie serious or nor
did I expect it to be high quality I
expected it to be kind of outrageous and
it was in a certain way and it was also
crazy and it's kind of dumb and it's
[ __ ] silly but that's what I knew it
was gonna be that way yeah I mean if you
go into it knowing I mean I went into it
knowing that it was gonna be dumb but I
was still expecting it to be funny but
it just after I was gonna was like you
know some of those [ __ ] really bad
action films from the 8th
I mean where it's just [ __ ] Blom
blond bimbos with rocket launchers
shooting down helicopters literally
[ __ ] models clearly models of
helicopters and [ __ ] dudes with
mullets and [ __ ] 44 Magnum automatics
III what I mean and it was something
that you know you saw at midnight on
[ __ ] TNT Channel
yeah it was one of those yeah I knew
it's gonna be something like a hard
ticket to Hawaii
yeah a hard ticket to Hawaii it wasn't
as funny as that well I wasn't trying to
be funny
I know but yeah but it's still it's
still funnier than right well this is
kind of like imagine if airplanes
okay was done by the same dude who did
hard ticket to Hawaii it would be like
that and also he had had half of his
brain removed III think it I got my
$2.99 worth if I was [ __ ] truck out of
delighted you liked it even I probably
would have to I wasn't drunk enough to
yeah if I struck a light and it was
something that you would just put on to
[ __ ] laugh at you know and I and I
have a feeling that the movie was made
very quickly I have a yeah because a lot
of it seemed kind of incompetently done
and this is not like the director has
made movies before like movie made good
movies before so I don't really know
this just seemed like it was like a
throwaway it looked like the whole most
of it was taking place in in the
airplane yeah and I have a feeling that
a lot of that might have been filmed
only in three or four days yeah that was
a proper ëismí in the right and like I
said it's just
and then things were added like certain
special effects scenes were added to
catch it together I mean but I it is
what it is yeah you know I mean it this
movie is what it is I mean it was like
something that you yeah like if you like
parodies and stiffly yeah I didn't find
it particularly funny I just like I said
it's all the jokes seems really really
obvious and it seemed very much like a
90s like sub scary movie type of thing
which I didn't really think those are
particularly funny either just because
it seemed everything is obvious they
never you know what I mean it's like you
can see every single joke coming from
like a mile away
if I was 14 or
fifteen I would have thought this [ __ ]
was [ __ ] hilarious
yeah all right I'm 50 years old the
people who are doing this making this
program I could tell they didn't really
think it was that funny okay but of 1416
year old they probably think this [ __ ]
was [ __ ] hilarious especially with
skinny little [ __ ] but by laying
running around with her [ __ ] boobs
popping out on top of her [ __ ] yeah
and then lesbian vampire lesbian [ __ ]
lesbian nuns possessed by the devil and
[ __ ]
they would have loved that [ __ ] yeah
team your six-year-old loved this movie
and that's that was the target yeah
that's yeah that's you know yeah it's
cuz they couldn't rent porn or something
or you but yeah I don't know although
now all that think that's what I mean
nowadays 15 to 16 years you don't need
you don't need as you can get right
little bit even better back in the 80s
yeah this seems like kind of a movie out
of time got a little bit out time I can
see how they were trying to omage that
but it just I don't know it's just it
kind of fell flat for me I think but you
know if it sounds like something you'd
be into yeah you can run it for it's
only a couple bucks more bucks or how
much of this and you can laugh with or
add the movie you have a thing or both
at the same time and then you know I
recommend [ __ ] tequila I was gonna say
I recommend booze or possibly weed
both yeah for Mexico don't don't expect
Citizen Kane or [ __ ] night you know
[ __ ] the greatest story ever told what
composes well don't even expect don't
even expect airplane or scary money
because it's not even so you know but
whatever everybody's got different
tastes a movie there's a b-movie
and it sounds like some [ __ ] be like I
said there's a lot of famous people in
it so you kind of like watch you know
and be like hey what are they doing in
this room you know what I made this a
b-movie but yeah so so check it out or
don't I don't like it
you
all right third movie we watched four
matinee this week was another one that
we rented on Xbox don't we don't want to
see this one for a long time because we
saw the trailer like a few months back
and we were like hey that looks pretty
good this is an animated movie Superman
Reds
yeah the Communist Superman yeah this is
from I guess it's from there was a back
in 2003 there was like a three volume
graphic novel from there what is it
called there elsewhere series yeah it's
a parallel universe
yeah they see what you're talking about
is that in you're talking about like the
mirror universe in Star Trek yeah I
don't like that and the premise is is
what would happen in another universe
the premise is there's another universe
of what Superman ended up in a so landed
in the Soviet Union
yeah and was raised drowned in communism
and was friends with Stalin and
everything and it's fascinating really
it's not the same Soviet Union you know
per se it's a difference an alternate
one and the United States is an
alternate one it's it so it's an
alternate universe
so some so when they're talking about
the Soviet Union it's not exactly the
same Soviet Union you know and the
United States is not exactly the same
United States either it's a different
one yeah but there is a lot of political
content in it and a lot of a lot of I
would call it prior like criticism of
political systems both communism man you
know not in non communist States and
it's it's but it's still a [ __ ] good
movie yeah yeah I liked it it was
alright
there was uh some obvious political
messaging in there but I didn't mind it
too much it was you know well you have
to think too that this came out it's not
really
commenting on [ __ ] that's happening
today it was cuz the the story came out
to see history yeah and it was the thing
about it too and one criticism that I've
seen and I don't know how accurate this
is because I haven't read the the
three-volume you know graphic novel that
it's based on was that you know they
left a lot of stuff out because
apparently you know the book they go a
lot more into detail about like all the
political [ __ ] and everything but I mean
you have to think this is an hour and a
half animated movie you can't really put
everything in there probably would have
been a miniseries right have been better
as a mini which maybe it would have um
but that said just do a pretty solid I
actually really yeah I thought this was
like a really solid animated movie you
know the animation is just about what
you would see on like that Batman one
that animated Batman one that fan in
mask of the phantasm or whatever the
hell that was that came out a while back
it kind of looked like that it was
really nice like old fashioned like
animation it's not like you know
computer-generated or anything and it's
really kind of an interesting I have to
say like everybody in the alternate
universe because everybody's in this not
just Superman there's Batman Wonder
Woman and Green Lantern sort of yeah and
you know Brainiac yeah Brainiac Lex
Luthor Lois Lane everybody is in this
but they're like different versions
versions of them and like some of them
are like reverse yeah what's weird is
it's almost kind of like almost kind of
medieval it has a very medieval feel to
it like in the same way that the Star
Trek meet at the Star Trek Mirror
Universe is very kind of medieval yeah
the mentality is different
a lot more savage in a way Batman is a
terrorist he's trying to overthrow
Superman and get rid of the Soviet Union
to take Russia back you know so in a way
kind of like an ultra-nationalist
Wonder Woman's kind of a man-hater yeah
Lex Luthor is Lex Luthor is a hero have
an America good guy look at some douchey
qualities but he does kill people but
he's usually like yeah and he's more of
a heroic figure right she's married
she's married to Lois Lane yeah who's
like kind of uh kind of a feminist but
also in the relationship because the sex
is good and that he's further in her
career which is some weird [ __ ]
I liked it though man everything was
kind of [ __ ] weird about it's like I
said it had a medieval v to it the
United States was real capitalist but it
was still better than the Soviet Union
because the Soviet Union was kind of
like had slave gulags and [ __ ] like that
it's just you just gotta watch movie for
yourself I mean it's like it's a really
great I can see why like the guy that
wrote the original you know the 2003
comic book Mark Miller I think his name
is you can see how he's he said he got
the idea back in the early 2000s when he
had read like an old Superman comic that
said like something about Superman
landing in the ocean like between the
United States and Russia and he got to
thinking he's like even when he was a
little kid he's like man what would have
happened if Superman had landed in the
Soviet Union and he had been ways
differently and stuff like how would
that play out so he was like thinking
about this even from when he was like 13
or 14 years old it was like a
fascinating topic to him because it was
almost kind of like you could go into
like nature versus nurture like you know
would Superman turn out the same even
though he was raised in a completely
different system as he came out yeah and
the answer is no he wouldn't be the same
he well he had like a lot of similar
traits and he did kind of yeah man that
dude was it's hard to say that dude was
doing a lot he was [ __ ] totalitarian
dictator who was trying if I can bring
about the [ __ ] utopian one-world
government and he he he made the Soviet
Union swallow up all the entire nations
of the planet except the United States
the United States was like the last
holdout and then really whoever wrote it
they didn't really quite get the
politics straight
I don't think because Superman was
trying to endorse like basically global
communism that's what he wanted when
that didn't work the United States said
well we're gonna make a global
government which is really like more the
same so you'll have to draw the
conclusions to yourself you know also I
like when world governments just don't
go work is because it's just a one size
fits all
just can't work I feel like that Lex
Luthor cloned a Superman essentially and
made made him superior man superior man
I thought it was funny like when he came
out and he said I give you a superior
man I'm like of course American versus
gotta be even bigger and better and
[ __ ] more like a dick like America he
was gonna like yeah not quite that bad
but you know it was like so he wasn't a
natural creation though yeah and
Superman in the Soviet the communist
version of Superman I guess you could
say he kind of became the Superman that
we would know that's what I was gonna
say like you know tom boylar alert yeah
you know what I mean it kind of does I
mean I guess it's not too much of a
spoiler because like the the book spent
outside he thought he was doing the
right thing to create it you I hope you
so he was a victim more of naivete you
run than action Stalin held him that
stardom told him that he was too naive
and for the world and he was sheltering
him he's got seed it's good it's it's
solid movie I yeah I like like I said I
haven't read the book I have read that
like people were like mad that it didn't
go as much into depth into the
characters into the political situation
into the whole question of nature versus
nurture and stuff as the book did but I
mean you know reasonably there's only so
much you can do like in a movie this
short so I think they did an admirable
job with what they had and it's like a
fascinating thought experiment and like
I said I have to say that like all of
the character the the kind of Soviet
versions of all the characters look way
cooler than their regular like
Superman's kind of like Soviet outfit
and like I like I liked Wonder Woman's
kind of more Soviet looking at all the
red and everything Russian Batman was
pretty cool yeah so it's like so
everyone like looked a lot cooler
because I've always loved that aesthetic
and I have to say like the opening
sequence
I [ __ ] love the the whole look of
grass
yeah you're big into art déco looking
stuff yes yeah I love that kind of [ __ ]
I've always loved that kind of look but
yeah this is definitely definitely worth
checking out if you're into Superman if
you're into DC Comics or into the enemy
of this kind of stuff this just came out
in late February I think so this is
probably one of the most recent movies
that we've done in the last few weeks
for me Superman is always gonna be
Christopher Reeves it's Superman one and
two Superman three wasn't that good you
know him but Superman one and TuneIn the
Donner cut so Superman one was a [ __ ]
masterpiece for me that's Superman
alright the tone was right but this one
I would include it in there that this is
this was a solid Superman movie oh yeah
first up you know an alternate version
of Superman
I liked it yeah and like I said if you
like I think what the [ __ ] are those are
those alternate universe DC comics
called elsewheres LCCC yeah something
like that
but yeah they have like a whole line of
like hey take that character and like
put him in a different like an alternate
universe and see what happens like you
said like the Star Trek mirror universe
but yeah it's you know if you like
animated movies if you like DC comics if
you like any of that stuff you haven't
seen it yet somehow yeah I recommend it
I had I really thought I you know I
enjoyed it and I thought it was like
fascinating seeing those characters in
like a different context you know I
found that really interesting so you
know check it out
[Music]